REGULARLY SCHEDULED BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE
HEARING FOR TUESDAY APRIL SIXTH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US AS A REMINDER LIKE TO THINK
STAFF AGAIN FOR HELPING TO PUT
TOGETHER THE AGENDA DUE TO THE
CURRENT STATE HOME WATER WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE
THING HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
AND THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING WE ALSO REQUIRING THAT
MUST BE WORN AND FISCAL
DISINFECTING BE MAINTAINED BY
ALL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TESTIFYING WHETHER NOT HERE IN
THE ROOM. OR AT THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING SITE. WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY FOR
MEMBERS AND THE PUBLIC HEARING
THE CHAMBERS WE CAN ONLY
ACCOMMODATE A MINIMAL
CONTINGENT OF STAFF AND ALSO. A
PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN
MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF SPACING.
WE KINDLY ASK THAT IF MEMBERS
IN THE PUBLIC ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN A BILL PLEASE
REFER HAND WHEN WE WILL MAKE
SURE THAT YOU APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. FOR DIAL IN WITNESSES
PLEASE NOTE THAT WE ARE USING A
MODERATELY TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH. WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE FOUR ACCESS
CODE IS. TWO FOUR TWO SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN AGAIN THAT'S EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE FOUR ACCESS
CODE IS TWO FOUR. TWO SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN. IF YOU ARE CALLING
IN PLEASE. BE SURE TO- NOTE THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL THAT YOU'RE
TESTIFYING AS THEY BEGIN THEIR
PRESENTATIONS. IF YOU HAVE
HAVING PROBLEMS WITH A MODERATE
TO PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CAL
THE COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX
THREE ONE NINE. THREE THREE
ZERO ONE AND WE WILL BE SURE TO
HELP ASSIST AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
NOW TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
PLEASE NOTE THAT TODAY WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF ITEMS ON CONSENT
WHICH WILL BE TAKEN ONE SICK
QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED. THAT IS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO TWENTY FIVE
BY SOME MEMBER GRAY AB TWO
NINETY EIGHT BYE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OR ONE AB THREE FIFTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER
AB FOUR THIRTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN SB SIX
NINETY BY SOME REMEMBER
ARAMBULA A. B. THIRTEEN OH FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LACKEY AND
AGAIN WE WILL TAKE THOSE ITEMS
UP ON CONSENT ONCE A QUORUM IS
ESTABLISHED. IN ORDER TO GET
THROUGH THIS HEARING
SUCCESSFULLY PLEASE BE SURE TO
SPEAK LOUDLY AND CLEARLY INTO
THE MICROPHONE AT THIS POINT IF
YOU ARE NOT VOTING ON A BILL AS
WELL TWO MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE PLEASE INDICATE CELL.
SO THAT THE COMMITTEE SCRETARY
CAN MAKE SURE THAT YOU ARE HURT.
HAVING SAID THAT THEN WE'LL GET
INTO- THE GENDER WE NOTICED THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM BUT- A
PRESENCE OF THE CURRENT VICE
CHAIR AND ALSO AS THE- NUMBER
OF AUTHORS THAT ARE HEREAND
WILL BEGIN THEN AND FILE ORDER.
SO WE'LL BEGIN AGAIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE THIS IS. FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
BILL. TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. BAUER-KAHAN
ASSEMBLY WONDER PLEASE FEEL
FREE PRESENT WHATEVER READY.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
ARMCHAIR HERE TO PRESENT AB
TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH
PROHIBITS DIFFERENTIAL PRICING
ON THE BASIS OF GENDER
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE PINK TAX.
I WANT TO START BY TALKING
ABOUT HOW HARD WOMEN HAVE BEEN
HURT BY THIS PANDEMIC. THE
ECONOMIC INEQUITIES BETWEEN MEN
AND WOMEN HAVE ONLY INCREASED.
ALL THE NATURAL GLASSES HAVE
BEEN FROM WOMEN AND
SPECIFICALLY WOMEN OF COLOR. AS
SHOWN IN THE DECEMBER JOB
NUMBERS. THAT IS ON TOP OF THE
ARTICLE PAY THAT WOMEN STRUGGLE
WITH TO THIS DAY DESPITE THE
VALIANT EFFORTS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE WOMEN STILL MAKE
SIGNIFICANTLY LESS THAN MEN.
AND ON TOP OF THAT THEY PAY
WHAT IS KNOWN AS THE PINK TAX
WHICH IS PAYING MORE FOR AN
IDENTICAL PRODUCT SIMPLY
BECAUSE IT IS BEING MARKETED TO
WOMEN. MULTIPLE STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT WOMEN ON AVERAGE PAY
7% MORE FOR GENDERED ITEMS LIKE
TOILETRIES AND CLOTHING THEY
FACE HIGHER PRICES FOR
SEEMINGLY NEUTRAL PRODUCTS LIKE
MORTGAGE RATES. THESE PRICE
DIFFERENCES ADD UP I CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE STUDY ESTIMATED THE
YEAR AFTER YEAR A TYPICAL WOMAN
PAYS ABOUT TWO THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY ONE DOLLARS MORE
FOR THE SAME GOODS AND SERVICES
THAN HER MALE COUNTERPART. THIS
ARBITRARILY PENALIZES WOMEN TO
THE TUNE OF FORTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR. K. HIGHER
PRICES BECAUSE OF YOUR GENDER
IS UNJUST AND FRANKLY UNLAWFUL.
IT HURTS WOMEN IN A MARKET WHEN
THEY ARE ALREADY DEEPLY
VULNERABLE. THIS BILL STRIKES
AN IMPORTANT BALANCE WE WORK
HARD TO CRACK THE BILL WITH THE
PROPONENTS AND THE OPPONENTS OF
THE PREVIOUS ITERATIONS OF THIS
LEGISLATION AND I'M PROUD TO
SAY THAT THE CHAMBERS NEUTRAL
ON THE BILL. AND WE ARE
PROTECTED SMALL BUSINESSES FROM
THE BURDENSOME LITIGATION WELL
STILL HOLDING RETAILERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE SYSTEMIC
GENDER IMBALANCE IN PRICING.
WITH ME TODAY ARE PROFESSOR IAN
ERRORS FROM YALE UNIVERSITY AND
TIFFANY BOYD LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE COMMISSION ON
THE STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY WOMAN-
IF WE COULD KINDLY ALLOW FOR A
TOTAL OF THREE MINUTES FOR THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
FEEL FREE 2% WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. GET YOUR CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS IAN AREAS- I
AND THE OSCAR AMERIHEALTH AND
PROFESSOR. AND DEPUTY DEAN OF
YALE LAW SCHOOL AND ALSO A
PROFESSOR AT YALE SCHOOL OF
MANAGEMENT. FOR MORE THAN
TWENTY YEARS I HAVE CONDUCTED
STATISTICAL TEST OF RACE AND
GENDER DISCRIMINATION AND A
VARIETY OF MARKET. THANK YOU
FOR LETTING ME SPEAK TODAY
ABOUT THE PROBLEM DIFFERENTIAL
PRICING OF GOODS MARKETED TO
MEN AND WOMEN AND WHY I BELIEVE
AB TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN IS A
WELL CRAFTED RESPONSE TO THIS
PROBLEM. THERE IS ABUNDANT
EVIDENCE THAT NATIONAL
RETAILERS HAVE BEEN FOUND TO
CHARGE HIGHER PRICES ON
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR SO
CALLED. PINK GOODS MARKETED TO
WOMEN THIS IS A LONG STANDING
CONCERN IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA STUDY
THE ISSUE GENDER BASED PRICING
OF SERVICES AN ESTIMATED THAT
WOMEN PAY. A GENDER TAX OF
APPROXIMATELY THIRTEEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY DOLLARS MORE RECENTLY
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN AN EXTENSIVE
STUDY OF GENDER PRICING IN NEW
YORK CITY COMPARED THE PRICES
OF. NEARLY EIGHT HUNDRED
PRODUCT ERRORS WITH FEMALE AND
MALE ANALOGS AND FOUND THAT
WOMEN'S PRODUCTS COST 7% MORE
THAN- SIMILAR PRODUCTS FOR MEN.
FOR EXAMPLE THE STUDY FOUND
THAT CVS SOLD A PINK STOOL
SOFTENER THAT COST 30% MORE
THAN ITS BLUE COUNTERPARTS.
THERE WAS NO DIFFERENT IN THE
INGREDIENT LIST FOR THESE
TABLETS. JUST THE DIFFERENT
PINK PACKAGE AND A DIFFERENT
PRICE NINE DOLLARS AND SEVENTY
NINE CENTS VERSUS SEVEN DOLLARS
AND FORTY NINE CENTS. A WELL
KNOWN MARKETING STRATEGY. IS TO
CREATE A WOMAN'S VERSION OF A
PRODUCT BY TO PRODUCING THAT.
END UP PEPTO BISMOL PINK SHADE.
THE NEW YORK CITY- STUDY
INCLUDED PHOTOS OF DOZENS OF
PRODUCT CARE. WITH THE SHAPE
SIZE INGREDIENTS WERE VIRTUALLY
IDENTICAL BUT JUST THE COLOR OR
LABELING WAS DIFFERENT. FOR
EXAMPLE IF FOUND THE TARGET
SOLD THE PINK RED FLYER SCOOTER
FOR WHOPPING TWENTY DOLLARS
MORE THAN THE NEARLY IDENTICAL
RED SCOOTER MARKETED TO BOYS.
WITH A PRICE DIFFERENCE OF.
FORTY FOUR NINETY NINE VERSUS
TWENTY FOUR NINETY NINE.
GENDERED PRICE OF THIS. SO THE
DISK. OF FOUND ACROSS OF
VARIETY OF I AND RE. FOR
EXAMPLE WALGREENS IS FOUNDED
CHARGE 23% MORE ON- IT'S
WOMEN'S SHIPPED HYDRO FIVE
RAZOR CARTRIDGES TARGET CHARGED
87% MORE ON A PINK BIKE HELMET.
URBAN OUTFITTERS CHARGES 25%
MORE ON WOMEN'S. CLOTHING IN
SOME INSTANCES THESE HIGHER
PRICES FOR WOMEN PRODUCTS MIGHT
BE JUSTIFIED BY DIFFERENT ARE
DIFFERENTIALLY HIGHER
PRODUCTION COSTS FOR EXAMPLE
THE TOP DETAILING A WOMAN'S
BLOUSE. MIGHT MAKE IT MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN THE CAUGHT THE
KILLER IN THE SIMILAR MEN SURE.
BUT AB TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN
EXPLICITLY RESPONSE TO THIS
CONCERN BY NOT PROHIBITING
PRICE DIFFERENCES THAT ARE
BASED ON THE DIFFICULTY OR COST
OF MANUFACTURING. THAT THE
DIFFERENT PRICES CHARGED FOR
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR PRODUCTS
THAT ARE EXPLICITLY MARKETED TO
DIFFERENT GENDERS
DISPROPORTIONATELY HURTS WOMEN.
CHARGING THAT HIGH THAT THE
MARKET WILL BEAR IS NOT A
BUSINESS JUSTIFICATION FOR THIS
THIS PROGRAM PACKED. AB TWELVE
EIGHTY SEVEN APPROPRIATELY
RESPOND TO THE RAMPANT PROBLEM
OF GENDER PRICING WERE
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR PRODUCTS-
PRICES ARE CHARGED FOR
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR PRODUCTS.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME SPEAK
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND-
OF WE'VE- THE THREE MINUTES BUT
I KNOW THAT THERE'S AN
ADDITIONAL PRIMARY WIN THIS AND
SO- IF IT I BELIEVE IT'S- THIS
BOY OUT FROM THE COMMISSION ON
STATUS OF WOMEN. AND GIRLS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRS AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS TIFFANY BOYD AS
MENTIONED I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
THE STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS.
THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
STATUS WOMEN GIRLS THERE THAT
THE INDEPENDENT ADVISORY
AGENCY. TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR OF POLICY AND
OTHER ISSUES PERTAINING TO THE
SYSTEMIC CONDITION. AFFECTING
EQUITY ON WOMEN AND GIRLS IN
CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO COMMEND
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION FORWARD WE
KNOW THAT WOMEN AND GIRLS
CONTINUE TO FACE AN ARRAY OF
ANY QUALITIES IN MANY ASPECTS
OF THEIR DAILY LIVES. MANY HAVE
WHICH HAVE BEEN WORSENED BY THE
COBIT NINETEEN PANDEMIC. ONE
SIGNIFICANT AND SYSTEMIC
BARRIER TO EQUAL ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY FOR WOMEN. IS THE
PINK TAX AND AS MENTIONED IT IS
A SUBSTANTIAL FINANCIAL IMPACT.
TO HAVE THIS GENDER BASED
PRICING DISPARITY. AS MENTIONED
IT WITH ROUGHLY FORTY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS EACH YEAR-
COSTS WOMEN ACROSS CALIFORNIA
IT IS UNACCEPTABLE THAT IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WOMEN AND
GIRLS ARE STILL ASSIGNED THE
BURDEN OF PAYING MORE FOR
SIMILAR GOODS. THAN MEN.
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE ACTED IN
RESPECT TO GENDER BASED
DISCRIMINATION. AND THE SCALE
OF SERVICES SUCH AS HAIRCUTS
DRY CLEANING. AND ALTERATIONS
OVER A QUARTER CENTURY AGO IN
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE. I'M GOING
PRICES IN PARTICULARLY. I
BETWEEN PRESS HEALTH. SPORTS
EQUIPMENT AND TOYS. ARE CLEAR
EVIDENCE THAT CONSUMER PRESSURE
IN EXISTING LAWS ARE
INSUFFICIENT AND WE NEED A
LEGAL GUARANTEE. OF THIS
PARTICULAR EQUAL TREATMENT
UNDER THE LAW. TOLERATING
DISCRIMINATORY PRICE SETTING
REINFORCES SOCIETAL SIGNALS
ABOUT THE VALUE OF GENDER WHERE
WOMEN ARE. VALUED AND WHERE
THEY ARE NOT WOMEN ALREADY PAID
LESS THAN MEN AND WITH THE P.
TAX OR CHARGE MORE ON TOP OF
IT. AB TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN IS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT
WOMEN'S RIGHTS TO EQUAL
TREATMENT BY ENDING GENDER
BASED PRICING. SAFEGUARDING THE
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY OF WOMEN IS NOT
JUST ABOUT WOMEN. ABOUT ABOUT
THE PROSPERITY OF CHILDREN
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES
ELIMINATING TAXES A COMMON
SENSE ACTION TO GET US ONE STEP
CLOSER TO ACHIEVING FULL
EQUALITY. AND PARTICIPATION OF
WOMEN AND GIRLS IN OUR STATE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS MISS POINT. NOW ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
GALLERY WISHING TO SPEAK ON
THIS ITEM IN SUPPORT C. NINE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
ANY THE- COMMITTEE ROOMS
WISHING TO SPEAK ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE NOW OPEN UP THE-
THE LINES FOR ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT ON OUR PHONE LINES
AGAIN- THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT NAME AND AFFILIATION IF
YOU WISH TO DO SO. PLEASE FEEL
FREE WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK
UP. TO THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
PRESS ONE ENTER AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE SEVERAL
PEOPLE OF SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. THANKS JUST A MOMENT
PLACE.
AND AGAIN AS PARTNERING
UP- JUST A NAME AND A FILIATION
AND YOUR POSITION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AND WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO LINE FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. LINE. THIRTY FOUR.
GOOD MORNING SHARE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THAT CONDUCTED A
GARDENER ON BEHALF OF EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. AND FINALLY LINE.
EIGHTEEN IMPACT FROM THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MISTER CHAIR
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH JIM WILL PAUSE
FOR A MOMENT TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. LOW HERE FOR ARAMBULA
BERMAN. HELLO CHEN. Q.
CUNNINGHAM DALY FONG GIPSON
GRAYSON HOLDEN. IRWIN MCCARTY.
MEDINA MULLIN. SALAS FOR SOME
PEOPLE CHANGE. CALAVERAS SHE'S
ONLY GOT. ARE YOU. ONE FIFTY
REFORM. CORPORATIST GLOBALIST
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A CORE AND THEN I
WILL GO TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
THE CHAMBERS LISTEN TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION C. NINE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU KINDLY OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL.
TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN. FOR THOSE
OF YOU WHO WISH TO SPEAK AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE
ZERO PRESS ONE AND ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR NO ONE SIGNALED THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOW- BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY. OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. GET THIS
INTO MOTION AND A SECOND ANY
ADDITIONAL. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SEEING NONE ASSEMBLY
ONE. BAR CAN DO WISH TO CLOSE
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND THE CHAIR FOR THEIR HARD
WORK ON THIS AND
ASTRONOMICAL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING IN THIS SPACE AND
HELPING TO ENSURE THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HEADS IN
THAT DIRECTION FOR. GENDER
EQUITY ESPECIALLY IN THIS AND
CLIMATE THIS DOESN'T DO I DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION THERE'S
BEEN A MOTION AND A SECOND
COMMITTEE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB TWELVE EIGHTY
SEVEN POWER QUE HAN TO PASS TO
DJ SHERRY LOW HI. LOW HI FLORA.
FLORA HI ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE
BERMAN. BLOOM BLOOM HI CHAN
CHEN AYE CHIU. CUNNINGHAM DELLY
DELLY IPHONE. FONG I GIPSON
GIPSON HI GRAYSON GRAYSON HI
HOLDEN. IRWIN WHEN I MCCARTY.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE SALAS. TANG
TANG HI CALAVERAS. CALAVERAS I.
THIRTEEN I ZERO KNOWS THAT HAS
THIRTEEN AYE VOTES WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY WOMAN WILL NOW MOVE ON
THEN TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
WHICH IS AB FOURTEEN OH SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN BURKE SOMEONE
BURKE PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
AB FORTINO SEVEN SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION IS A MEASURE
DESIGNED TO EDUCATE OUR HEALTH
CARE WORK FORCE ON THE IMPACT
OF IMPLICIT BIAS IN OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM. IN ORDER TO BRING
DISPARITIES AND NEGATIVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES TO AN AND SPECIFICALLY
AB FORTINO SEVEN REQUIRES
NURSING PROGRAMS AND HOSPITALS
TO INCLUDE IN HIS IMPLICIT BIAS
EDUCATION FOR NURSES EVIDENCE
EXISTS THAT SUGGESTS THE
PRESENCE OF IMPLICIT BIAS IN
THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM LEADS TO
DIFFERENT SETS IN QUALITY OF
CARE GIVEN TO PATIENTS AND THE
OVERALL HEALTH CARE OUTCOMES
THE SAME EVIDENCE SUGGESTS THAT
MORE OFTEN THAN NOT PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND WOMEN ARE THE ONES TO
BE NECK LIVES NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED. BY THIS IMPACT. IN A
HEALTHCARE SETTING DECISIONS
AFFECTED BY BIAS CAN HAVE LIFE
AND DEATH IMPLICATIONS AT MATH
AS IT MANIFESTS ITSELF IN
SUBTLE DIFFERENCES IN HOW
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS. INTERACT
WITH PATIENTS THE DIFFERENCES
IN HEALTH CARE TREATMENTS. THIS
IS UNACCEPTABLE AND MUST BE
ADDRESSED. WE KNOW THAT EFFORTS
HAVE BEEN MADE TO REDUCE
IMPLICIT BIAS IN THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM. AND THERE IS A
DEMONSTRATED COMMITMENT BY
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES AND
EDUCATORS FOR MITIGATING
NEGATIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES. THOSE
EFFORTS MUST CONTINUE IF WE'RE
TO MAKE STRIDES TOWARD
ADDRESSING THE HEALTH NEEDS OF
OUR STATE MANY DIVERSE
POPULATIONS. AB FORTINO SEVEN
WILL BROADEN THOSE EFFORT TO
BRING AWARENESS. TO THESE
ISSUES BY REQUIRING IMPLICIT
BIAS EDUCATION FOR NURSES AND
OUR STATE. IS ANOTHER STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION TOWARDS ANY
ENDING NEGATIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES
IN MEETING THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE COMMUNITY.
WITH ME IN SUPPORT ITS CURRENT
LAYING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- OPERATOR WOULD YOU
KINDLY OPEN OF THE LINES FOR
THE PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT
AND AGAIN WILL LIMIT THE
TESTIMONY TO UP TO TWO MINUTES.
FOR THE A PRIMARY WITNESS
MISTER LANG PLEASE FEEL FREE
PRESENT WHENEVER READY. YOU
MISTER CHAIR GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF LANGUAGE
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION. ALFONSO'S OF AB
FOURTEEN OH SEVEN. WE WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE FOR
HER LEADERSHIP IN INTRODUCING
THIS BILL. WHICH REQUIRES
IMPLICIT BIAS EDUCATION FOR
NURSING STUDENTS AND YOU ARE
AND I THINK THE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE INDICATED. BY THE-
THE IMPLICIT BIAS EXISTS AMONG
PEOPLE OF ALL QUESTION. HOWEVER
WHEN INPUT DEVICE CHRIS THIS
MAY HEALTHCARE SPENDING IT MAY
CONTRIBUTE TO THE HEALTH CARE
DISPARITIES EXPERIENCED BY
MEMBERS OF RACIAL ETHNIC. OR
RELIGIOUS MINORITIES AND OTHER
GROUPS. THE PREVALENCE OF
IMPLICIT BIAS IN THE HEALTHCARE
SETTING IS REFLECTIVE OF BEING
ADDED WE- ENACTED SCENES YOU
NEED. WITHIN THE HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM AND STRUCTURE. TOO OFTEN
THE BUILDINGS BUILT TO LOOK AT
COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE. THOSE
COMMUNITIES NEEDS AND
RESOURCES- THE THIRTY NEED TO
TAPPED. FILL THOSE NEEDS. OF
CHARACTER EVEN EDUCATORS MUST
DEMONSTRATE THEIR COMMITMENT TO
ENDING RACIAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES. AND WORKING TOWARD
HEALTH EQUITY BY AGGRESSIVELY
PURSUING STRATEGIES THAT
ELIMINATE IMPLICIT BIAS WITHIN
THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. AB
FOURTEEN OH SEVEN RECOGNIZES
THAT AWARENESS AND EDUCATION IS
THE FIRST STEP TOWARD
ELIMINATING. THE BIAS IN THIS
SETTING. EDUCATING THE FUTURE
HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE SO THAT
THEY ARE COGNITIVE ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF IMPLICIT BIAS THE
PATIENTS THEY SERVE. IS
PARAMOUNT. TO BRING THIS
PHENOMENON TO AN END. IN THE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE EIGHTY FORTY NINE. ALSO
I'M AVAILABLE TO ANY TO
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATOR EITHER ANY
AND WITNESSESWHICH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AT THIS FILLED TO OPEN
THE LINES AGAIN THIS FOR
MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY. FOURTEEN
ZERO SEVEN. THANK YOU WHICH
CHAIR AND FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
WISH TO SPEAK. BUT FOR THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE VENTURA
AT THIS TIME PRESS ONE THEN.
ZERO WE HAVE ONE PERSON WHO
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
JUST A MOMENT.
WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO LINE THIRTY PARDON ME.
WE'RE GONNA GO TO LINE THIRTY
SIX. HI JENNIFER MALLEY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
IN SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE ONE
ADDITIONAL PERSON WE'RE GOING
TO GO TO LINE THIRTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JEAN HURTS CALLING IN TODAY ON
BEHALF AT THAT COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. MISTER
CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEE NO
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT NOW
GO TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WITNESS BEGIN OPPOSITION
HERE ON THE LINE FOR ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN ZERO SEVEN. AND
ONCE AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO. PICTURE NONI SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE THIS DOESN'T
JOINT DO PASS RECOMMENDATION I
SEE A QUESTION OR COMMENT FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON. SECOND
I THANK YOU CHAIR I WOULD MAKE
THIS COMMENT AGAIN- LATER ON IN
THE HEARING I KNOW THAT AS
EXPECTED WITH CERTAIN
PROFESSIONS THERE ARE- A LOT OF
REQUIREMENTS ESPECIALLY THE
BURDEN ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE
LICENSED OR REGISTERED- IN
CONSIDERATION TO THE BURDEN OF
CONTINUING EDUCATION SO I WAS
JUST LOOKING HERE LOOKING AT
THAT ONE. WHAT IS THE BURDEN ON
OUR NURSES RIGHT NOW AS FAR AS
CONTINUING EDUCATION I REALLY
APPRECIATE WHAT THE AUTHORS
DOING HERE AND I AM VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF IT. IT'S WE JUST
START PILING ON MORE AND MORE
AND CONTINUING EDUCATION COST.
IT ALSO TAKES TIME SO I WAS
JUST WONDERING IS THERE A
FIGURE OR OR WHAT IS THE BURDEN
THAT ALREADY EXIST ON OUR OUR
NURSING. A PROFESSION AS FAR AS
CONTINUING EDUCATION ON OUR
ANNUAL OR- EVERY TWO YEAR BASIS
IS THAT INFORMATION READILY
AVAILABLE IF IT'S NOT THEN- I
COULD ALWAYS. GET A LITTLE
LATER. I'M SURE CURTIS CAN
ANSWER THAT. SURE YEAH I DID
JUST A COMMON THEN AS SOME A
WOMAN AND PERHAPS IN YOUR
CLOTHES AS THERE'S BEEN IN
MOTION AND A SECOND. AS
IMMIGRATION THANK YOU ALSO FOR
BRINGING THAT UP AS YOU'VE BEEN
VERY DILIGENT IN OUR
INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS ALSO ON
THE SUNSET OF THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING AND PERHAPS
THEY CAN ALSO BE ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS TO BE HAD.
SPECIFICALLY WITH THIS
LEGISLATION AND ALSO INTO
TALLADEGA ON THAT OF THE BOARD
ITSELF TO ON TO ECHO SOME OF
THOSE COMMENTS SO ASSEMBLY
WOMAN- BURKE D. WHICH TO-
ANSWER ANY CALL YET- SO. I
APPRECIATE THE MEMBERS COMMENTS
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS
A BURDEN HOWEVER IMPLICIT BIAS
IT'S BEEN AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
THAT I'VE WORKED ON I'M PROUD
TO GOTTEN. LEGISLATION SIGNED
IN UP FOR OTHER PROFESSIONS AS
IT RELATES TO IMPLICIT BIAS AND
SO ALTHOUGH THERE MAY BE
CUMBERSOME ISSUES AS FAR AS
CONTINUED EDUCATION. IMPLICIT
BIAS IN MOST OF THESE
PROFESSIONS THAT I'M WORKING ON
ARE A REALLY LIFE AND DEATH
PROFESSIONS AND- HAVE PROVEN
DATA THAT IMPLICIT BIAS HAS
BEEN AN ISSUE. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THIS DOES ENJOYED
PASS RECOMMENDATION THAT'S BEEN
IN MOTION AND A SECOND
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB FORTINO SEVEN
BURKE TO PASS TO HEALTH LOW
HIGH LOW HIGH FLORA. FOR NOT
VOTING ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA HI
BERMAN. BLOOM. BLOOM AYE CHAN
CHAIN IQ. DALY DALY IPHONE. I'M
NOT VOTING GIPSON- GIPSON HI
GRAYSON- GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN WHEN I MCCARTY. MEDINA
MEDINA HI SALAS SALAS FIGHTING
KING HI CALAVERAS VOTERS BY.
TWELVE FIVE ZERO KNOWS TELEVIZE
WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS. THEY CALL
THIS ONE- NOW MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT ITEM- THIS IS. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB TWO TO FOUR AND
JUST IN THE MEANTIME THEN IF
WE'LL JST- GET A MOTION ON
CONSENT. THE CASE HAS BEEN IN
MOTION AND A SECOND PROCEDURE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THIS IS
FOR CONSENT. CONSENT AB TWO TO
FIVE GREAT TO PASSED A MILITARY
VETERANS AFFAIRS EIGHTY TO
NINETY PER ONE EIGHTY THREE
FIVE NINE COOPER AB FOUR THREE
FIVE MULLIN EIGHTY SIX NINE
ZERO ARAMBULA AB THIRTEEN OH
FIVE LACKEY TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. LOW HI LOW HI
FLORENCE LAURA HI ARAMBULA
GRANULOCYTE BERMAN. BLOOM BLOOM
AYE CHAN CHEN AYE CHIU. DALY
DALY AYE FONG. FONG AYE GIPSON-
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON- GRAYSON I
TOLD IN. IRWIN MCCARTY. MEDINA
HI MEDINA HI SALAS SALAS
FIGHTING KING I BALLADARES
MILITARES I. THIRTEEN IS EIGHT
ZERO KNOWS K. THIRTY NINE WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS COLLEAGUES
WERE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS AB TWO
TWENTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DALY ASSEMBLY WERE DALY THIS
DOES ENJOY DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES
I'LL- FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SO I APPRECIATE THE
HARD WORK OF. OF THE COMMITTEE
CHAIR AND STAFF AND WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS FOR THIS BILL- BOB
BOBBY BRIEF THIS BILL
MODERNIZES OUR STATE STATUTE BY
PROVIDING A DISTINCTION BETWEEN
TRADITIONAL FULL SERVICE MOVING
COMPANIES. AND SELF MOVING
SERVICES PROVIDED BY MOTOR
CARRIERS- I APPRECIATE THE-
SUPPORT RECOMMENDATIONS FROM-
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE AND NOW.
ALL ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
COME UP I DO HAVE TWO SPEAKERS
CHRISTIAN MOTOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
AND SHANE GUSMAN WITH THE
TEAMSTERS. VERY MUCH WILL NOW
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR PUBLIC
PRIMARY AS TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
IF YOU COULD KINDLY LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES EACH- IS THIS MURDER
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHEN YOU'RE READY. MORNING
CHERYL OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PUSH MODEL CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION. AB TO CHECK FOR
UPDATES CALIFORNIA LAW TO
REFLECT ACTION TAKEN BY
CONGRESS IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIVE TO GIVE CONSUMERS A LOWER
COST ALTERNATIVE FULL SERVICE
HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS. UNDER
FEDERAL LAW MOTOR CARRIERS
AUTHORIZED TO PERFORM A LIMITED
RANGE OF SELF MOVING SERVICES.
SELF MOVING PROVIDE GESTURE
WILL IMPACT THEIR OWN HOUSEHOLD
GOODS ARE COST EFFECTIVE LOW OR
NO TOUCH SOCIAL DISTANCE MOVING
OPTION AT IS NOT TOO BAD THE
TWENTY FIVE. PERCENT SAVINGS
OVER A SERVICE NEIGHBORS. BY
LORNE FOR TRAFFICKING HOME
REDUCING. EIGHTY EIGHTY SUPPORT
FOR HELPING AT THAT COULD NOT
WELL BEING CAL. WHO REMOTE.
THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY ASK I
THOUGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT CHAIN. FOR MORE MR SHOULD
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE CHAIN
THAT'S BEEN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS PROUD BECAUSE BY THIS
BILL I'LL BE VERY BRIEF- ARM.
WORK FOR FOUR MAJOR TRY
COMPANIES THAT THAT DO THAT
WORK AND GET- THEY ARE. OVER
AND WRONGLY REGULAR AS-
HOUSEHOLD GOOD MOVERS- IT
COULDN JEFF THEIR JOB IN AND SO
WE'RE THANKFUL FOR THIS
CLARIFICATION- IN THE LAW AND
WE URGE ARRIVAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AGAIN THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO INDICATE YOUR SUPPORT
WITH NAME AND AFFILIATION ONLY.
IF YOU WISH TO DO SO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND FOR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. MISTER
CHAIR KNOWING THE SIGNAL THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SEE NO ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
CHAMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. NOW MOVE ON TO MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. SEE NO MEMBERS
IN OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS OPERATOR WOULD YOU
KINDLY OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHICH
IS BEGIN OPPOSITION. ON
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO TWENTY FOUR.
FOR THOSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION THE BILL TO TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE VENTURA
AT THIS TIME. FOR OPPOSITION TO
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO. MISTER CHAIR NO ONE
TO SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF ANY MISTER TERRACES I'M NOT
SURE IF YOU CAN HEAR ME YES WE
CAN AND WE ARE REALLY IN THE
QUEUE IS THE OPPOSITION WITNESS.
THANK YOU I'M SORRY FOR THAT I.
ON ALERTS IN EVERY JUST ON ACT
OF BRIEF BUT IS NOT. I WISH I
YOU'RE A SHALL LANG I BE OUT
WITH. MOVING TO HAS. I WANT TO
THANK YOU CAN STAFF THEIR WORK
ON AB TWO FOR THE LAST FEW
STARTED PORTUGAL. WE WERE MADE
UP OF TO THE BILL. AND THE
AMOUNT OF SNOW WE BELIEVE THAT
SOME LAW COULD GIFT. YEAH TO
BREAK IT THE TRAIN. OF
HOUSEHOLDS WITHIN BORDERS. AND
THE FOCUS OF EXISTING REGULATE
DOES NOT CENTER WHO WILL DRAW
ON THE TRUCK. THE RATHER THAN
TRANSPORT OF HOUSE GOODS- OVER
THE WORLD. IT IS WHEN HOUSE
GOODS ARE ENTRY. THE ARE MOST
RISK. BILL WOULD WEAKEN
CONSUMER. BY ALLOWING COMPANIES
ENGAGE IN THE TRAY. OUR WHOLE
GOODS TO EXAMPLE. FROM STATE
OVER. AS DO. IT WOULD NOT
MATTER IF COMPANY INTRODUCED
PLACEHOLDER TRIPS. YOU TO.
COULD FULL HOUSE GOODS. OR AT
THE OFFICE. IN THE HOUSE OF. A
CUSTOMER YOU. A CELL MOVING.
COME LIKE POSSIBLY PROMOTES. AS
A MOVING. CAN CONSUME ALL. OF
THE MOVIE. AS YOU CAN SEE IN
DATA PER. BY THE BUREAU ALSO
GOODS. ARE PAGE EIGHT NINE OF
THE BALANCES. THE CONSUMER CAN.
IN THE- INTO. ARE OVER. FOCUSED
ON LIFE ACTIVE. WE BELIEVE THE
PUBLIC. OF COME. REGARD ON LIFE
ACTIVE WILL CONTINUE.
SUCCESSFUL AND CARRIERS OF
HOUSEHOLD GOODS ARE ALLOWED
DISTRICTS TO LICENSE OR-
FINALLY. PERMITTING FOR IS NOT
COMP BUT BEER THE NEXT RESOURCE
FOR COMPANIES SEEKING LIKE. AND
ALLOW. HELD BY THE COMPANY AND
NOT BY THE END OF THE DRIVER OR
PULL. BECAUSE A COUPLE OFFER
HOUSEHOLD GOODS MOVE SERVICES
DID NOT ISSUE HAPPEN LICENSED
BY THE STATE. IT IS NOT A JOB
TO. REASON TO REMOVE OUR BILL
TO PUT CONSUMER THANK WE ARE. I
RESPECTED ASK FOR YOUR NOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOTED
MEMBERS OF THE WE SHOULD TO
SPEAK IN OFFICE. THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION IN A SECOND ASSEMBLY
DAILY DO YOU WISH TO CLOSE. I
RESPECT ASK FOR YEARS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE DOES
ENJOY TO PASS RIGHT. COMING
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE- AB
TWO TO FOUR. DO AS A TO A- LOW
HI LOW HIGH. FLORA I ARAMBULA.
RAMBLE I BERMAN. BERMAN I BLEW.
BLOOM CHEN. CHEN AYE CHIU. THE
DAILY DALY I. FONG I- HI GRACE-
GREAT AYE HOLDEN. IRWIN AYE
MCCARTY MEDINA HI NINE SALAS I
SALAS ALL RIGHT TEAM. TEN NINE
CALAVERAS MILITARY SITE. FIFTY
EYES ZERO. EIGHTEEN IS WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE FOR A MY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MEMBER DALY WHEN
I MOVE ON TO FIVE AND ARE NOT.
NINE NUMBER SEVEN BUT WE- DO
NOT SEE THE AUTHOR THIS IS FILE
ITEM SEVENTY WE'LL MOVE ON TO
FILE I NUMBER EIGHT. WHICH IS
S. BILL THIRD. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SMITH ABUSED FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT WHENEVER READY THIS
DOZEN CHOI DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE AISLE. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AB NINE THIRTEEN UPDATES AND
CLARIFIES. THE COLLATERAL
RECOVERY ACT IN THE BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONAL CODES. TO
REFLECT THE CURRENT BUSINESS
PRACTICES. THE BILL ALSO UPDATE
HOW A NOTICE OF SEIZURE FOR THE
INVENTORY OF PERSONAL EFFECTS
MAY BE DELIVERED TO THE DEBTOR.
TO REFLECT CURRENT BUSINESS
PRACTICES BY AUTHORIZING THE
NOTICES TO BE DELIVERED BY
EMAIL. THE MAJORITY OF THE
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL PASSES
COMMITTEE UNANIMOUSLY LAST YEAR.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO THE
SHORTENED SCHEDULE AND LIMITED
HEARINGS DID NOT MAKE IT TO THE
FINAL PRODUCT IN THE SENATE. I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. I HAVE
JOE COLLINS AGV AIRS AVAILABLE
REMOTELY TO SPEAK ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
LICENSED REPRESENTS SURF IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL
NOW OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
PRIMARY WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT IF YOU COULD
KINDLY LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO
NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES EACH
BILL 3% WHATEVER READY. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS CHIEFLY ERRORS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION LICENSE REQUESTERS-
WE ARE THE SPONSORS AND IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL PLEASE THIS
BILL CLEARS UP CONFUSION-CONFLICTING PROVISIONS NUMBER
CONCESSION LAW MODERNIZES THE
LAW. CURRENT CONSUMER FOR PRICE.
AND ENABLE TO PROVIDE OPERATE
EFFICIENTLY EFFECTIVELY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT- JOE-
JOE COLLINS. BACK CALAVERAS
LEGISLATIVELY ALSO HAS
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS THAT MONEY IS
JOE ARE REPRESENTS TELEPHONE
SEARCH LICENSING. ANSWER
QUESTIONS BUT TO. THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NUMBER OF THE- LINE
FOR MEMBERS OF THE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OPERATOR WOULD
YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE THIRTEEN.
AND FOR THOSE WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PRESS. ONE ZERO.
MISTER CHAIR NO ONE HAS BUT NO
ONE IS A SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
OPERATOR OTHER ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PBLIC WITNESS BEGIN
OPPOSITION THE CURRENTLY ON THE
LINE. FOR THOSE OF YOU WISHING
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIR NO ONE IS SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL- BRING THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE THERE'S BEEN IN
MOTION AND A SECOND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. THAT YOU WISH TO CLOSE.
I APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COMMITTEE SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. EIGHTY NINE THIRTEEN
SMITH DO PASSED A PUBLIC SAFETY
LOW HIGH LOW HIGH FLOOR ON THE
FLOOR HI ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE
BERMAN. BERMAN I AM FLUENT.
LOOM HI CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU.
DALY DELLY IPHONE. FONG HI
GIPSON- GIVE AYE GRAYSON-
GRAYSON HOLD. EARLY WHEN I
MCCARTY MEDINA HI MEDINA SALAS
SALAS BY. FIFTEEN HI BALLOT.
THERE IS A HIGH. FIFTEEN AYE
ZERONOS FIFTEEN I BELIEVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BECAUSE IN A- PAST DOUBLE THEN
OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR AND THIS
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN
TIME WITH ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
SIXTY TWO. ALL RIGHT MISTER
CHAIRPERSON IN THE ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES AND
MEMBERS OF THE THIS IS A SYMBOL
FIVE SIXTY TO THE FRONTLINE
COVERED NINETEEN PROVIDER
MENTAL HEALTH RESILIENCY ACTIVE
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE WE LIKE
TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AS LISTED IN ALICE'S
AND AS YOU KNOW THIS BILL WILL
HELP PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH.
SERVICES FOR HEALTH CARE
LICENSEES ESPECIALLY IF THEY
ARE HELPING TO SUPPORT US IN
THIS GREAT TIME OF NEED ON THE
LINE IN SUPPORT ARE ADDITIONAL-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
REPRESENTING YOU KNACK MICHELLE
BAKA WRIST REGISTERED NURSE
AND- FROM CSA ANTONIO HERNANDEZ
CONTACT. RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATIVE WE OPEN UP THE LINES
FOR SUPPORT PLEASE. PARDON ME
MISTER CHAIR WAS THAT FOUR
WITNESSES YES WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE SIXTY TWO.
THEY'RE ON THE LINE THEIR LINES
ARE AVAILABLE TO OPEN AND SPEAK.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WELL CHAIR AND MEMBERS
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY.
OUR TOPIC OF THE MENTAL HEALTH
OF COULD BE NINETEEN FRONT RANK
CARE PROVIDERS. MY NAME IS
MICHELLE PARKER I'M A
REGISTERED NURSE. IN THE
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT SAN MARINO
COUNTY AND NUMBER OF THE UNITED
HERE ASSOCIATIONS OF CALIFORNIA
YOU KNOW HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS. BUT WHEN
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS HAVE BEEN
WORKING FOR MORE THAN A YEAR TO
TREAT PATIENTS WITH COPD IT.
AND WE ARE NOW FINALLY ABLE TO
PAUSE AND REFLECT ON THE
IMPACT. IT HAD ON THE- I WOULD
HAVE CARED FOR. YEAH MY BEEN
ABLE TO ADEQUATELY CARE FOR.
PLEASE SEE OUR OWN WELL BEING
ON BACK BURNER. MANY OF US ARE
NOW TO BEGIN TO REFLECT ON THE
PAST YEAR AND START ARE
GRIEVING PROCESS. I HAVE CARED
FOR HUNDREDS OF PUBLICATIONS.
MANY OF WHOM DIED ALONE LOVE
GOING BACK THERE. MANY TIMES WE
WERE THE ONES WHO PEACE PAN.
LONDON THAT THERE COULD GIVING
YOUR CHAT RECAP. HELLO DURING
THE HEIGHT OF THE- WAS OFTEN
POP TO BE A TO SPEND THAT
QUALITY TIME WITH ACTIVELY
DYING. AND WE HAVE OTHER OKAY
FOR OUR IMMEDIATE ATTENTION.
THIS AREA IS NOT KEEPING
ANYTHING AND NOR THROUGHOUT MY
SCHOOL. IN THE COUNTRY. GOING
HOME AFTER EACH SHIFT AND ABOUT
THE- WHO LOST THEIR LOVED ONES
WHO DEPRIVED OF THE ABILITY TO
THINK BY. OR KISSING ONE LAST
TIME BECAME AN IN. BURKE ON MY-
THE- AND FEAR ACCORDING TO THE
PARKING LOT OF WORK. AND
WONDERING PATIENTS A BY THE
NIGHT OF THE WEEK IN WOULD
CRUSH. CRYING ON THE WE NEED
AND FROM. BECAME A THING
ROUTINE. MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
CALLED ON THE- THAT THEY
SENTIMENT AT WORK AND DURING
OUR PRIVATE. THANK WITH YOU MY
BUT I SAY WITH CONFIDENCE MY-
BE IN THE- A COUNTLESS OTHER IN
THE CAR THE HELP. SEVEN PROCESS
AFTER THIS UNPRECEDENTED HERE.
THIS IS WHY I AM GRATEFUL TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WELL FOR
OPERATING- AUTHORING EIGHTY
FIVE FIFTY TWO WHICH WILL
PRIORITIZE HEALTH SERVICES FOR
COMPANIES CARE PROVIDER
PROVIDER. WE NEED YOUR HELP
SUPPORT THE PROFESSION I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I
VOTE. FOR EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY
TWO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF AB. FIVE
SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS DR
ANTONIO HERNANDEZ PONCIANO
MCCARTY AT THE RAPID PHYSICIAN
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS AT THE KAISER
PERMANENTE A LOS ANGELES
MEDICAL. CENTER I AM ALSO THE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY
OF ANESTHESIOLOGISTS
LEGISLATIVE IMPROPER FAIR
POSITION THE CALIFORNIA
PROVIDED ANESTHESIOLOGIST IS
PROUD TO CO SPONSOR EIGHTY BY
TWO PHYSICIAN ANESTHESIOLOGISTS
ARE GUARDIANS OF PATIENT SAFETY
IN THE OPERATING ROOM IN THE
DELIVERY ROOM. IN INTENSIVE
CARE UNIT IN PAIN MANAGEMENT
CLINICS AND MOST RECENTLY ON
THE FRONT LINES OF THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. PHYSICIAN
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS UNDER TO OVER
TWELVE YEARS OF EDUCATION AND
TRAINING TO NAVIGATE CRITICAL
LIFE AND DEATH MOMENT IN ALL OF
YOUR PROCEDURAL AREA. AND WE
ALSO PROVIDE EMERGENCY SERVICES
AND SERVICE AIRWAY MANAGEMENT
EXPERTS FOR THIS TICKET TO
PATIENTS DIAGNOSED WITH AND
PEPPERING COVERED NINETEEN. THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT PHYSICIAN
ANESTHESIOLOGISTS WERE MADE FOR
THIS MOMENT HOWEVER PHYSICIANS
LIKE THAT AS WELL AS NURSES AND
OTHER FRONTLINE HEALTH
PROVIDERS HAVE BEEN UNDER
EXTRAORDINARY STRESS DURING THE
PAST YEAR WORKING LONGER HOURS
DAY AFTER DAY IN TOUGHER
CONDITIONS THAN EVER BEFORE.
THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY
ANESTHESIOLOGIST WANTS TO MAKE
SURE THEY ALL HAVE ACCESS TO
EFFECTIVE AND CONFIDENTIAL
MENTAL AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
RESOURCES THAT NEEDED. WE NEED
PHYSICIAN ANESTHESIOLOGISTS AND
OTHER FRONTLINE HEALTH CARE
WORKERS TO STAY MENTALLY STRONG
AND PHYSICALLY HEALTHY SO THEY
CAN CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THE
BEST. CARE POSSIBLE FOR THEIR
PATIENTS. THEREFORE THE TF
STRONG BELIEVE EIGHTY FIVE
SIXTY WILL CREATE NEW TOOLS TO
MANAGE BURNOUT AND- LAUNCHED
TRY OF. WITH BEING FIRSTHAND
THE- EFFECT THE NINE. OFFER
HEALTHCARE DESERVE TO RECOUP
AND MOVE FOR WHICH WE WITH. AS
WE RECALL FROM THE- IMPACT OF
THE PANDA HEARING HEALTH.
LASTLY WE WILL LIKE TO
ESPECIALLY THE CHAIRMAN LOW AND
BY YOUR LARA STEPS LEADERS ON
THE ISSUE. THANK YOU YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND FOR ALL THESE
THREE WHICH URGE YOUR I THE
EIGHTY FIVE TWO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
ON THE LINE AND- OF AB SIX TWO
NAME IN ORDER. ONLY PLEASE. WHY
MATURE. M. PARDON ME MISTER
CHAIR WHERE YOU INVITING NO
COMMENTS FROM THE PUBLIC NOW.
THAT IS CORRECT. OKAY SO LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT ON THIS BILL IN SUPPORT
AT THIS TIME PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO WE HAVE SEVERAL PEOPLE
LOSE SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
WE'RE GOING TO GO FIRST TO IN
LINE. FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MY NAME IS KRISTOFF MEYER AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR WORK ON THE ISSUE.
THANK LINE FORTY BILL. I'M
FORTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
RECTANGLE REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN NURSES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LINE. FORTY THREE. THANK YOU MR
CARE MEMBERS PRICE DOUGHERTY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. LINE TWENTY
FOUR. ADRIN MOHAMMED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
COSPONSORS OF THE SPELL IN
STRONG SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR
THERE IS NO ONE L. TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE IN THE CHAMBER
IN THE GALLERY IN SUPPORT. C.
NINE. OPERATOR HAVE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION. TWO EIGHTY FIVE
SIXTY TWO OPPOSITION. AND ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME PRESS
ONE THEN. ZERO MISTER CHAIR NO
ONE IS SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION IN THE
CHAMBER. SEEN NINE WILL BRING
BACK TO THE CAN- TO THE
COMMITTEE. THE QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. SCENE NINE- I
JUST ALSO LIKE TO THINK OF THE
CHAIR FOR HIS- WORK ON THIS I
KNOW THIS HAS BEEN A LOT OF FUN
WORKING WITH YOU AND THEN I
ALSO NOTE VINCE IN YOUR STAFF
HAS BEEN WORKING VERY VERY HARD
TO THINK EVENTS ARE FOR YOUR
DILIGENCE WITH THIS MATTER AS
WELL BUT THE THIS IS A GREAT
BILL AND THERE'S NOTHING MORE
IMPORTANT OUR FRONTLINE WORKERS
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS GUY
PANDEMIC SO THE GREAT BILL TO
WORK TOGETHER ON AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH BUT
YOUR FLOOR AND TAKE YOU OUT TO
YOU IN YOUR OFFICE ALSO IF THE
A PARTNERSHIP ON THIS AS WE HAD
A CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS EARLY
IN THE YEAR AND INCEPTION ABOUT
WHAT WE CAN DO TO HELP EASE THE
PAIN AND SUFFERING FOR THOSE
WHO ARE HELPING TO SAVE
EVERYDAY LIVES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR ANY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB FIVE SIX TWO LOW TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO HELP LOW
HIGH LOW HIGH FLOOR HIGH FLOOR
I ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA ALL RIGHT
BERMAN. BERMAN HI HELLO. BLOOM
HI CHIU. CHAN RIGHT. DALY DELLY.
ONE NIGHT GIPSON GIPSON GRAYSON
GRAYSON HI. EARLY AYE MCCARTY
MEDINA IN A NICE SALAS SALAS HI
TEAM KING HI VALLADARES
MILITARES I. FIFTEEN NINE ZERO
NO THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH
FIFTY NINE HOLD OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS MISTER CHAIR PRESENTING
AB TEN EIGHTY FOUR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES AND
MEMBERS THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN EIGHTY FOUR. TO REQUIRE
RETAILERS WITH FIVE HUNDRED OR
MORE EMPLOYEES TO PROVIDE A
GENDER NEUTRAL RETAIL SECTION
OF FOUR CHILDREN'S ITEMS IF THE
RETAILER CHOOSES TO SIMPLY
LABEL TOYS OUR KIDS. THAT IS
ALSO THE OPTION AS WE KNOW
THERE ARE MANY RETAILERS WHO
ARE ALREADY GOING INTO SPACE.
NAMELY COMPANIES LIKE TARGET
MADE HEADLINES BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN MINUTE
DECIDED TO GO AWAY WITH GENDER
BASED SIGNS TO ENSURE THAT KIDS
CAN BE KIDS. WHY SHOULD A GIRL
WHO WISHES TO WEYRICH TEACHER
WITH A DINOSAUR ON IT. HAVE TO
BE SHAMED AND FACE STIGMA GOING
TO THE BOYS SECTION SIMPLY PUT
LET'S LET KIDS BE KIDS AS YOU
KNOW THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
ALSO GONE IN THIS DIRECTION. A
PREVIOUS YEARS UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF SOME OF THESE
NUMBERS HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE
ON GENDER NEUTRAL BATHROOMS AS
WELL- SO WE HOPE TO CONTINUE ON
THE INCLUSIVITY HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WITH WITH
WITH ME TODAY ARE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT OF FIRST
OFF. WE HAVE ROB SMITH WHO
BEGAN HIS LONG CAREER SPANNING
OVER THIRTY YEARS GAINING NEW
EXPERIENCES. AS THE CHILDREN'S
GLOBAL CHIEF PRODUCT OF OFFICER
FOR NIKE LEVI'S JORDAN HURLEY
AND CONVERSE- TODAY ROB LEADS
AND MANAGES THE FOOD PROJECT
LEADER IN GENDER FREE FASHION.
AND THE SECOND WITNESS SAID
TODAY IS. THE AUTHOR ALSO OF MY
A CO AUTHOR. AND CHIEF OF
BRITAIN. SO RESPECTFULLY ASKING
FOR A VOTE AND LOOKING FORWARD
TO THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH RESEARCHER FIRST
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. WHO'S WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK FIRST. ROB
PLEASE IF YOU DON'T MIND.
YOU'VE GOT IT- THANK YOU ALL
FOR- INVITING ME TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THIS BILL- PRETTY
PASSIONATE ABOUT IT OBVIOUSLY
THROUGH MY CAREER THIRTY YEARS
AND RETAIL AND BEFORE BY THE
WAY BEFORE LEVI'S AND NIKE I
WORKED FOR MACY'S FOR TWENTY
TWO YEARS SO I UNDERSTAND.
DEEPLY THE- THE OPPORTUNITIES
AROUND RETAIL- BUT ALSO THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT LAWS CAN BE
CREATED TO SUPPORT- INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE OFTEN LIVE- WE'RE LIVE
IN THE MARGINS. OF OUR SOCIETY
AND CALIFORNIA'S DONE AN
EXCELLENT JOB AND AS WITH THE
GOVERNMENT HAS CONTINUED TO DO
TO CREATE. AN UNDERSTANDING OF
THE SPACE. BEYOND THE BINARY
AND UNIVERSIDAD THAT YOU KNOW
WHAT IT IS TO BE A BOY WHAT IS
YOUR GIRL JUST WANNA LET
EVERYONE KNOW I VISITED- KIDS
DEPARTMENT THE OTHER DAY. AND
IN IN JUST JUSTICE GIVE ME AN
IDEA FOR AS A BUSINESS PERSON
AS A CONSULTANT ALSO FOR LOTS
OF RETAILERS. THE GIRL
DEPARTMENT READ. FOLLOW YOUR
DREAMS SMILE STAY HAPPY BE YOU
LOVE IS THE WAY TO BE COOL BE
KIND. THE BOYS DEPARTMENT READ
LEGEND YOUR ATTIC FUTURE HERO.
MAKE THAT MAKE THE WOULD MAKE
TODAY COUNT WORLDWIDE VISION
DUDE. SO THIS MESSAGING WE'RE
SENDING IS VERY- IS
SUPPRESSIVE. AND REALLY BUILD
IN THIS IDEA OF WHAT IT IS W
THINK OF IS TO BE APPOINTED THE
GIRL AND MORE MORE NO PARENTS
ARE BEGINNING TO RAISE THEIR
KIDS WITHOUT THESE. IDEAS AND
WE'RE ALREADY DOING IT RIGHT
NOW I'M SPEAKING WITH LARGE AND
CONSULTING WITH LARGE COMPANIES
HOW TO CREATE THIS SPACE IN
BETWEEN. WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
IT FORCES THE CONVERSATION IT
DOESN'T ALLOW. COMPANIES TO
DRAG THEIR FEET ANYMORE. AND
ALLOWS FOR A SPACE IN BETWEEN
FOR FOLKS WHO IDENTIFIER
THERE'S IS NOT BINARY OR THEIR
SELF EXPRESSIVE AND- THE
OPPORTUNITY JUST LIKE KIDS THE
KIDS YOU KNOW KIDS ALL HAVE THE
SAME BODY SHAPES. YOU KNOW AND
LET MY KIDS BE KIDS AND THIS
LAW WOULD START TO FORCE IN THE
WAKE UP LEADERS AND RETAILERS.
TO CREATE THE SPACE BETWEEN-
AND I LIKE TO SAY YOU KNOW THIS
DOESN'T HURT ANYBODY THEY'LL
STILL BE BLUE SECTIONS OF PINK
SECTIONS IF THAT'S WHAT YOU
WANT FOR YOUR KIDS. BUT IT DOES
ALLOW FOR THAT KID IN THE
MIDDLE TO CREATE INTO SHOP ON
THEIR BEHALF AND AS A RETAILER
YOU CAN LITERALLY TAKE DOWN ALL
YOUR SIGNS RIGHT NOW BOYS AND
GIRLS. WE ONE MASSIVE GENDER
NEUTRAL KIDS DEPARTMENT- THIS
IS JUST A SMALL MUCH SMALLER
SALT. SO I AM FULLY SUPPORTIVE
AND- AND I COULD SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF A BEING WORKING FOR
BIG COMPANIES. THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN AND THIS HELPS PAVE. THE
WAY AND MOVING A LOT FASTER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUCH NOT
WHAT IN SUPPORT. EUROPE MORNING
CHAIRMAN SURVIVE KAREN I'M OF
THE CA MY NAME IS BERNARD AND
I'M NINE YEARS I THINK WE KNOW
A CAN EIGHTY FOUR BEGAN AT MY
YEAH BUT WITHOUT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOW IT WOULDN'T BECAUSE-
A REALITY. I AM ONLY NO NINE
ONE RICHARD MOST MY I NEVER I
NOT TO KEEP UP WITH A GOOD BILL.
AB TWENTY FOUR BUT ALLOW KIDS
TO REALLY THEMSELVES WHEN
WITHOUT FEELING LIKE THEY'RE
SOMETHING WRONG JUST BECAUSE OF
HOW TAX PLAYED. FOR THE. IF
THEY CAN'T IT WOULD BE IT BUT
MY STEP TOWARDS ENDING GENDER
STEREO. THANK YOU. THANK VERY
MUCH OPERATE ANYONE ELSE BUT I
WHEN FIRST YEAH IT'S A I HAVE
SET THE YOU'RE YOU'RE ON THIS.
POSTERS YOU THANK YOU. I WAS
VERY WELL. OPERATOR ANYONE ELSE
SINCE THE O THE LINE FOR TWO
EIGHT FOUR. AND THOSE WITH THIS
AND SO OF EIGHTY FOUR FOUR OF
TEN EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE ONE THE
NEW TO GROWTH THIS. WELL FIRST
GO TO. FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TAMMY
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T CURRENTLY
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL BUT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON IT
ME VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
ARTICLE. THANK YOU. LINE.
FIFTEEN MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
DHINGRA FEEL ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION TESTING ON A. B.
TEN EIGHTY FOUR AUTHORED BY
CHAIRMAN LOW WE CURRENTLY DO
NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION
ON THIS MEASURE IN LARGE PART
BECAUSE OF THE NUMEROUS
CONVERSATIONS. WITH ARIANNA'S
COMMITTEE CONSULTED MISFIRES
I'VE BEEN VERY PRODUCTIVE.
BEFORE TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THAT YOU'RE ON THE BILL
AND IT HAS TO JUST CIRCLE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH HIS
NAME AN ORGAN LEVINE. LINE.
FIFTY DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. SURE THERE IS NO ONE
ELSE TO SIGNAL THAT THEY WISH
TO SPEAK THANK VERY MUCH ANYONE
IN SUPPORT IN THE CHAMBER.
SCENE NINE. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION STOPPARD WE OPEN IT
UP FOR OPPOSITION FOR TEN
EIGHTY FOUR. FOR THOSE WHO HEAR
ME SPEAK. PARDON ME THERE SEEMS
TO BE A WITNESS MISTER CHAIR.
WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES. IN
OPPOSITION FIRST WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE. THANK YOU
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GREG BIRD
WITH THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
COUNCIL AND WE APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL- IN
REMOVING IT YOUR BAN ON
SEPARATING AT CHILDREN'S
CLOTHES AND TOYS BY SEX BUT WE
ARE STILL OBJECTING. TO THE
STATE DICTATING TO RETAIL
STORES HOW TO MARKET THEIR
PRODUCTS TO THEIR CUSTOMERS
FIRST OFF THE BILL IS CONFUSING
AND IMPOSSIBLE TO COMPLY WITH.
THE BILL REQUIRED THE RETAIL
STORE TO CREATE GENDER NEUTRAL
SECTION WHERE EIGHT REASONABLE
NUMBER OF ITEMS ARE PLACED. BUT
THE WORD THE BILL DOES NOT
DEFINE THE WORD REASONABLE NOR
DOES IT EXPLAIN WHAT ITEMS
SHOULD BE PUT IN THE GENDER
NEUTRAL SECTION. IN PARTICULAR
ITEM ISN'T. WHAT THAT GIVES
SOME CHILD OR ACTIVISTS THE
REASON TO COMPLAIN. WHO'S GONNA
RESOLVE THE DISPUTE. IF THE
BUREAUCRAT LAWYERS JUDGES NO
STORE WILL EVER BE EVER KNOW
FOR SURE IF THEY'RE COMPLYING.
A BILL LIKE THIS OPEN THE DOOR
TO A NEVER ENDING NUMBER OF
COMPLAINTS FROM ACTIVIST GROUPS
WHO DON'T LIKE THE WAY STORES
ARE MARKETING THE PRODUCT. TO
ONE SEX OR ANOTHER. RETAIL
STORE HAVE A RIGHT TO BE LEFT
ALONE TO DECIDE HOW BEST TO
MARKET THE PRODUCT TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS BASED ON WHAT MARKET
RESEARCH TELL THEM THE
CUSTOMER'S ONE. IT WILL NOT BE
PERFECT AND THEY'LL GET IT
WRONG SOMETIMES. BUT WHEN THEY
GET IT WRONG THEIR PRODUCTS
WILL NOT SELL THE MARKET WILL
DO A BETTER JOB OF MEETING
PUBLIC NEEDS THEN YOUR WALL
WILL. END TOMORROW CHRISTINE
THAT PROTECTS THE RIGHT TO FREE
EXPRESSION LIFEGUARDS NO ONE
INDIVIDUAL OR LEGISLATOR HAS
THE RIGHT TO TELL A COMPANY
OWNER. WHAT MESSAGES ABOUT
GENDER THEY CAN USE TO SELL THE
PRODUCT. STATE LEGISLATORS NEED
TO STOP FORCING THEIR PERSONAL
OPINIONS ON THOSE THEY DISAGREE
WITH. THIS IS AN ILLEGAL USE OF
THEIR POWER. LEGISLATOR SHOULD
RESPECT THE VIEWS OF OTHER
PEOPLE AND TRIED TO PERSUADE
THEM TO CHANGE THEIR MINDS IF
THEY THINK THEY'RE WRONG.
INSTEAD OF USING THE
LEGISLATIVE POWER TO FORCE
THEIR VIEWS ON OTHER. ISN'T
SIMPLY OBNOXIOUS. IT'S A
VIOLATION OF FREE SPEECH AND
IT'S JUST PLAIN WRONG. THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL
STRONGLY OPPOSES AB ONE EIGHTY
FOUR ENCOURAGES THE COMMITTEE
TO REJECT THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TEN EIGHTY
FOUR. NEXT WITNESS. YES CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING- MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
IS MATTHEW MCREYNOLDS SENIOR
STAFF ATTORNEY ON BEHALF OF THE
PACIFIC JUSTICE INSTITUTE
CENTER FOR PUBLIC POLICY- IN
OPPOSITION AB TEN EIGHTY FOUR
WE SUBMITTED A LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON DISTILLATE OUT
SOME OF OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
CONCERNS- I HOPE THAT YOU HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW THAT-
SO I WON'T REPEAT THAT WILL
JUST TOUCH ON A FEW THINGS REAL
QUICKLY. THE FIRST OF ALL I
THINK IT'S TELLING THAT THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS- DID NOT
DEAL WITH OUR FIRST AMENDMENT
AND OTHER COCERNS RELATED TO
THE BILL AT ALL INSTEAD-
STATING WEAKER ARGUMENTS
OFFERED BY OTHER GROUPS IN
OPPOSITION. AS PRIMARILY THE
BILL CONTINUES TO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS. RELATED
TO CONTENT IN VIEWPOINT-
DISCRIMINATION AND MANDATES OUR
SAILORS THERE'S ALSO
SIGNIFICANT. AMBIGUITY PROBLEM.
AND IN ADDITION TO THAT WE
WOULD NOTE POINTED COMMITTEE TO
BROWN VERSUS ENTERTAINMENT
MERCHANTS ASSOCIATION FOR THE
SUPREME COURT STRUCK DOWN AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY NINE SEVERAL
YEARS AGO WHICH WAS BASED ON A
VERY SIMILAR PREMISE THE NOTION
THAT PARENTS NEED HELP IN ORDER
TO SELECT APPROPRIATE TOYS FOR
THEIR CHILDREN. PARENTS NEED A
LOT OF HELP IN THE STATE BUT
THEY DON'T NEED POLITICIANS.
TELLING THEM HOW THEY SHOULD
SELECT TOYS FOR THEIR CHILDREN
AS WE TALK TO OUR CONSTITUENTS
ABOUT THIS LEGISLATION THE
DOMINANT RESPONSE IS THIS
BELIEF. THAT IN A TIME OF
GLOBAL CRISIS THIS IS WHAT
THEY'RE LEGISLATORS ARE
SPENDING THEIR- THEIR TIME IN
OUR TAXPAYERS MONEY DEBATING IS
THE WRONG TIME THE WRONG
APPROACH IN THE TWENTY ANALYSIS
MAKES IT MORE CLEAR THAN EVER.
THAT THIS IS HEAVILY
IDEOLOGICALLY DRIVEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR ORGANIZATION
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE LINE JUST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION ONLY PLEASE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE NINE ZERO IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO LINE
THIRTY NINE. PARDON ME WE PLUS
ONE THIRTY NINE JUST A MOMENT
PLEASE WE HAVE ONE OTHER PERSON
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK. WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK
TO LINE THIRTY NINE AGAIN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TELL ME ABOUT
IT CAPITAL RESEARCH INSTITUTE
IN OPPOSITION. LINE. FIFTY
THREE. ANY HERRINGTON FROM SAN
DIEGO COUNTY IN OPPOSITION. AND
WE HAVE ONE ADDITIONAL PERSON
THAT WISHES TO SPEAK JUST A
MOMENT PLACE. I'M GONNA GO TO
LINE FIFTY FOUR. HELLO YOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY OUR
MANAGEMENT FOR AND- AND BY ONE
NOT THIS CREEK- OR- IN THE
POLITICS ACCORDING TOOL BUILT
EIGHTY AND. EIGHTY FOUR. MISTER
CHAIR THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO
SIGNAL BUT THEY WISH TO SPEAK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
OPPOSITION AND GALLERY IN THE
CHAMBER. SENILE BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. ANY COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SCENE
NINE MISTER CHAIR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR VICE CHAIR OF BECAUSE
YOU HEARD OF SOME OF THE SECOND
WE NEED A MOTION AND SECOND
PLEASE. MISTER GIBSON MISTER
BLOOM THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A COLLEAGUE SAYS YOU MAY
HAVE HEARD FROM THE OPPOSITION
THAT THIS IS ONEROUS. BUT AS WE
STATED EARLIER THAT THIS IS
ALREADY IN PRACTICE BACK THIS
IS BEEN HAPPENING SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN SIR SIMPLY
CODIFYING WHAT WE ALREADY KNOW
IS IN PRACTICE. AND A GOOD
BUSINESS PRACTICES THAT THIS IS
A JOINT AUTHORED BY THE CHAIR
OF THE CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS AS WELL AS
MYSELF AS CHAIR OF THE LGBT
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB TEN EIGHTY FOUR HELLO DO
PASSED TO JUDICIARY LOW HIGH
LOW HIGH FLOOR NO. FLOOR NO
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA HEIGHT
BERMAN. BERMAN I FLEW. BLOOM HI
CHEN. CHEN NOT VOTING CHIU.
DALY DALY NO FONG. FONG NO-
GIPSON HI GRACE. HOLDEN HOLDEN
AYE IRWIN. WHEN I MCCARTY
MEDINA MEDINA NINE SALAS.
CHANGE OUR TEAM HI VALLADARES
MILITARY SNOW. NINE ICE FOR
KNOWS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
WILL BE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS AND THEN- COLLEAGUES
WERE OUR ON OUR FINAL BILL THIS
IS ASSEMBLY. BILL. FOUR SIXTY
FIVE FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
AGAIN A. B. FOUR SIXTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THIS ERIN PLEASE
FEEL FREE PRESENT WHATEVER
READY FOR THE BILL. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR PRESHEAF THE
SUPPORT I WILL BE BRIEF THIS
BILL REQUIRES A ONE HOUR OF
CULTURAL COMPETENCY TRAINING
FOR PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARIES
EVERY THREE YEARS UNDERSTANDING
AND APPLYING CULTURAL AND
ETHNIC DATA TO THE PROCESS OF
CARE. INCLUDING LGBTQ I PLUS
COMMUNITIES AS THE COMMUNITIES
AND RELIGIOUS COMMUNITIES SO
WITH THAT- WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE TAMMY MARTIN WITH THE
QUALITY CALIFORNIA AND JERRY
DOES MEN ON BEHALF OF THE
PROFESSIONAL PRODUCERS
ASSOCIATION. OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL- WITH
UP TO TWO MINUTES FOR TESTIMONY
FOR PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF BEGIN WITH TAMMY
MARTIN. H. THANK YOU SO MUCH
GOOD MORNING SHARING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF THE CANYON MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
WE'RE HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY
AND WITH CONSERVE EIGHTY FOUR
SIXTY FIVE. I WHICH I THE
AUTHOR DESCRIBES WHAT THE CLIP
OF NEW AND EXISTING
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARIES WITH
THE TOOLS THAT THEY NEED TO
EFFECTIVELY AND SENSITIVELY
ASSIST THEIR CLIENTS. WHO ARE
LESBIAN GAY BISEXUAL
TRANSGENDER OR INTERSEX ANY TO
ENSURE THAT PROFESSIONALS. CAN
FULFILL THEIR DUTY TO ACT IN
WAYS THAT ARE UNBIASED AND IN
THE BEST INTERESTS OF THEIR
CLIENTS MANY OF WHOM ARE
VULNERABLE TO BEGIN WITH. AN
LGBTQ I PLEDGE PEOPLE ARE NO
EXCEPTION MANY OF THEM HAVE
EXPERIENCED DISCRIMINATION IN
HEALTH CARE SPENDING LEADING
THEM TO DELAY NECESSARY CARE OR
AVOID IT ALTOGETHER. AND MANY
HAVE BEEN REJECTED BY THEIR
FAMILIES OR BEEN UNABLE TO
BUILD A FAMILY AND THEREFORE
HAVE FEWER OPTIONS FOR INFORMAL
CARE. PROFESSIONALS TO DO
CHERISE ARE CRITICAL RESTORED
TO OUR COMMUNITY WE THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR RECOGNIZING THE NEED
FOR THIS IMPORTANT BILL AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEE. SUPPORT TODAY AS
WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU NAY
UP MISS DOESN'T. BAKER MEMBERS
OF THE JURY DESMOND THE PREFER
PRODUCE AREAS TO HELP IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE WE WANT
TO EXTEND OUR APPRECIATION TO
THE AUTHOR AND TO THE SPONSOR
FOR DEVELOPING A DEFINITION OF
CULTURAL COMPETENCY DOUBLE WORK
FOR LICENSED PROFESSIONAL
FIDUCIARY HIM WE APPRECIATE THE
DEFINITION AS WELL AS THE
OBJECTIVE OF THE MEASURE. I
WOULD JUST ALSO ADD THAT TODAY
A LICENSED PROFESSIONAL
FIDUCIARIES HAVE A CONTINUING
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS- HEARING
THE CONVERSATION EARLIER IN THE
COMMITTEE ON A DIFFERENT BILL
WELL THERE ARE THIRTY HOURS OF
EDUCATION THAT ARE REQUIRED IN
LOSS BECOME PRETTY SHERRY AND
IN FIFTEEN HOURS OF CONTINUING
EDUCATION THERE ARE SOME
SUBJECTS ALREADY ELABORATED IN
THE BILL'S THE PROFESSION'S
CODE FOR THAT EDUCATION. AND WE
BELIEVE THIS IS A OF CURRENT A
CURRENT AND FINALLY. ADDITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATED YOU PLEASE A THE LINE
FOR ADDITION MEMBERS TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. THOSE
WISHING TO SPEAK AT THIS TIME
IN REGARDS TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO
MISTER CHAIR NO ONE IS SIGNALED
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND SEE NO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE IN
THE GALLERIES ANY WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
CURRENTLY ON THE LINE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINE FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN. ZERO MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE AT LEAST ONE LINE
WHO'S WHO'S WHO'S SIGNAL THAT
THEY WISH TO SPEAK JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE. AND WE'RE GONNA
GO TO LINE. THIRTY NINE.
EDITORIAL CAPITAL RESEARCH
INSTITUTE IN OPPOSITION. YEAH.
THERE IS NO ONE ELSE TO SIGNAL
THAT THEY WISH TO SPEAK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BACK TO THAT
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON THANK YOU JOE ALONE
AGAIN- ON THE SECOND BILL HERE
JUST TODAY ALONE- JUST WANTING
TO BE MINDFUL OF ADDING MORE
AND MORE- CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS ON THE PROFESSIONS
WHO ARE ALREADY INUNDATED WITH
A LOT OF CONTINUING IT DOES ADD
UP IT DOES TAKE TIME ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT'S A REQUIREMENT THAT
WE'RE MAKING- A REOCCURRENCE.
RATE CYCLE- EVERY SO OFTEN SO-
NOPE NO QUESTION I I'VE ALREADY
ASKED THE QUESTION ON THE OTHER
FROM THE OTHER OFFICE AND I AM
SUPPORTIVE OF THE INTENSE AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE VERY
AWARE AND EDUCATED SO THANK YOU
TO THE OFFER BUT- ONE OF JUST
MAKE SURE THE WORLD AWARE THAT
WE CONTINUE TO ADD. ON TO THESE
DIFFERENT PROFESSIONS. THEY YOU
VERY MUCH OF SOME GRAYSON FOR
THE CAN. AND ALSO AFTER THE
ISSUE OF A CONTINUED. A MANDATE
THAT WE HAVE IN THE CURRENT
CLIMATE- HAVING SAID THAT
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND ASSEMBLYMEMBERS THEIR
JEWISH TO CLOSE. UP I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE OF
MR GRAYSON I AM. COGNIZANT OF
YOUR CONCERN AS WELL IN FACT
WHEN I WAS WORKING ON THE BILL
THAT WAS ALSO ONE OF MY PRIMARY
CONCERNS LOCALLY- THE VIVE
PROFESSIONAL PRODUCERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. DID
WANT THIS BILL SO- SO IT WAS
EASY TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS.
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
WANT TO ALSO SAY THANK YOU TO
THE- COMMITTEE CHAIR FOR THE
WONDERFUL WORK ON ON THIS BILL
AS WELL PRECIADO VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NAZARIAN HAS BEEN IN
MOTION A SECOND. COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AB FOUR SIX FIVE NAZARIAN TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
HIGH. LOW HIGH FLOOR HI. I
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN I BLOOM BLOOM HI CHAN
CHAN ALL RIGHT YOU QIU BY DALY.
DALY HI FONG. FONG RIGHT-
GIPSON I AGREE BOB GRACE HI
HOLDEN HOLDEN HYPER- HI MCCARTY.
MEDINA I MEDINA HI SALAS SALAS
I. KING HIGH QUALITY BORDERS.
FIVE OKAY. SEVENTEEN ISER NEWS
SEVENTEEN I BELIEVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLLEAGUES WE'VE COMPLETED OUR
BILL PRESENTATIONS AND THEN
WE'LL GO NOW FOR ADDITIONAL ADD
ONS THAT WILL BEGIN WITHIN THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. CONSENT
CALENDAR EIGHTY TWO TO FIVE
GREAT PASSED A MILITARY
VETERANS AFFAIRS AB TWO NINE
EIGHT IRWIN AB THREE FIVE NINE
COOPER AB FOUR THREE FIVE
MULLIN EIGHTY SIX NINE ZERO
ARAMBULA AB THIRTEEN OH FIVE
LACKEY DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. CHIO I. CHU HI
HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
MCCARTY. BUT I APOLOGIZE IRWIN.
HI WHEN I. SIXTY NINE ZERO
NOTES ON SECOND SIXTY NINE THAT
THAT IS OUT THEN FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB. TWELVE EIGHTY
SEVEN. AB TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN
POWER QUE HAN TO PASS TO
JUDICIARY TO JUDICIARY. BERMAN.
BERMAN HI QIU QIU HI HOLDEN
HOLDEN HI MCCARTY. SALAS THE.
YEAH. SIXTEEN NINE ZERO KNOWS
SIXTEEN IS THE BILL IS OUT.
NEXT FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
FOURTEEN OH SEVEN DECEMBER AB
FORTINO SEVEN BURKE TO PASS TO
HEALTH. FONG. I APOLOGIZE UP
HOLDEN. HOLDEN I MCCARTY.
BERMAN BERMAN I. FORTY NINE
ZERONOS FORTY NICE THE BILL IS
OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER FOR A B.
TWO TWENTY FOUR BY SOMEONE OR
DALY AB TWO TO FOUR DAILY TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHIU. CHU HI
HOLDEN HOLDEN HI MCCARTY.
SEVENTEEN ISERNIA SEVENTEEN IS
THE BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY
FIVE IN THIS AREA. AB FOUR SIX
FIVE NAZARIAN TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. MCCARTY.
SEVENTY NINE ZERO KNOWS SEVENTY
NUYS THE BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB NINE THIRTEEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH. AB NINE
ONE THREE SMITH DO PASSED A
PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE. CHU HI
HOLDEN HOLDEN HI MCCARTY.
SEVENTY NINE ZERO NO SEVENTEEN
I THE BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM.
NUMBER TWELVE AB FIVE SIXTY TWO
LOW. AB FIVE SIX TWO LOW TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO HEALTH CHIU.
CHU HI HOLDEN HOLDEN I MCCARTY.
SEVENTY NINE ZERO SEVENTEEN I
THAT BILL IS OUT FINALLY FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB TEN
EIGHTY FOUR LOW. AB TWENTY FOUR
LOAD YOU DO PASSED TO JUDICIARY.
CHEN. GRAYSON. MCCARTY SALAS.
NINE NICE FURNACE. NINE ICE
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS. BECAUSE
BELIEVE THE OVERALL OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL UPDATES AT TEN
MINUTES FOR ADDITIONAL ADULT.
OKAY CONSENT ITEMS. AB TWO TO
FIVE GREAT TO PASSED A MILITARY
VETERANS AFFAIRS AB TWO NINE
EIGHT IRWIN DO PASTOR
PROCREATION AB THREE FIVE NINE
COOPER DEPRESSED APPROPRIATIONS
AB FOUR THREE FIVE MULLIN TO
PASTOR PROCREATION SB SIX NINE
ZERO ARAMBULA TO PASS TO
PROCREATION AB THIRTEEN OH FIVE
LUCKY TO PASS TO PREPARATION.
SEVENTY NINE ZERO KNOWS. AND AB
TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN POWER K.
HAND TO PASS TO JUDICIARY. HI
MCCARTY I. AB FORTINO SEVEN
BURKE TO PASS TO HEALTH.
MCCARTY HI MCCARTY AT.
AB TEN
EIGHTY FOUR LOW DO PASSED TO DO
SHERRY CHILL CHU I. MCCARTY
MCCARTY I. ELEVEN EYES FOR
KNOWS. AB TWO TO FOUR DALY. TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MCCARTY. THIRTY
I EIGHTEEN ISER ONUS. AB FOUR
SIX FIVE NAZARIAN TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS MCCARTY. TI.
SEVENTY NINE ZERO KNOWS. AB
NINE ONE THREE SMITH TO PASSED
A PUBLIC SAFETY MCCARTY. THIRTY
I. EIGHTY NINE ZERO KNOWS. AND
AB FIVE SIX TOO LOW TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO HELP MCCARTY MCCARTY
I. EIGHTY NINE ZERO KNOWS.
WE
ARE JOINED.